[Music]
hi I'm Rose a software engineer working
on Google's cloud spanner database and
hello again for me Heather and thanks
for joining us Rose glad to be here so
let's talk databases if you were
developing a new application what would
you say is more important data
consistency or scalability well normally
we'd have to choose between the two but
in today's episode we'll talk about
Google cloud spanner the first
relational database service that
provides both strong transactional
consistency and horizontal scalability
to thousands of nodes and towards the
end of this episode we'll also explore
the application of cloud spanner within
a self-paced lab let's get to it
cloud spanner is unique in the
marketplace because it combines both
relational database structure with
horizontal scale and performance what
this means is that this significantly
simplifies application development and
database management allowing you to
deliver your apps faster for example for
globally distributed apps cloud spanners
multi-regional configuration
automatically replicates a database
across continents allowing for localized
reads minimizing latency creating or
scaling such a globally replicated
database only takes a handful of clicks
at Google we use cloud spanner for our
own mission-critical services and apps
that billions of people access every day
so downtime just isn't an option it's
great that we can share this
battle-tested database service with our
Google cloud platform users cloud
spattered databases have an
industry-leading five nines of
availability SLA no plan downtime and
enterprise-grade security if you have a
traditional relational database system
that's bursting at the seams or are
struggling with hand-roll transactions
on top of an eventually consistent
database cloud spanner could be the
solution you're looking for
now it's time for quick labs in this lab
we'll show you how to use the GCP
console to create a cloud spanner
instance database and table we'll also
show you how to add a schema write data
modify it and run a query you can check
out the link to start the quick lab here
keep in mind that'll take about 30
minutes to complete at this point in the
lab we've created a spanner instance
created a database for the spanner
instance created a schema for the
database inserted some data into the
singers table now we're adding one more
item to the singers table next we will
select the item and click Edit make
changes to the item and click Save to
delete the item we will select it click
delete and click OK to confirm to query
the table we click query update the
query and click run query in this case
we get two singers that exist in our
table well that's the end of the episode
and we really hope you enjoyed it we'd
love to hear your feedback and how you
apply our services so please do share
and don't forget GCP offers a 12 month
free trial with 300 ollars and credits
so you can apply what you've learned
today and start using it with your data
if you want to learn more about cloud
spanner check out our training links
below thanks for watching and see you
soon